So
what if the truth could
unravel your entire life?
Yeah.
Well,
first of all,
it would,
and second,
yeah,
I know what you mean.
You mean what if I suppose a cardinal
case there would be that you did something
really terrible and then
if that was revealed,
it would be a catastrophic situation.
It's like without knowing
the details of that,
I can't provide a generic answer.
You know,
I think that there are some sins that
are so egregious that you don't get to
confess to them.
You know?
Like if you've done something terrible,
and I'm not recommending this,
it's just an example.
If you've done something terrible and you
know that if you revealed and it would
blow the lives of many
people around you apart,
it isn't obvious to me that you have any
moral justification for confessing just
to free your miserable soul.
So what if the truth could
unravel your entire life?
Or maybe you need to go to
Catholic confession and let
someone know exactly what
happened.
So you're clear about it then.
Then maybe what you need to do is to
swear to whatever God you worship that
you're going to try to walk the
straight and narrow from here on in.
And that'll be sufficient to atone for
whatever terrible thing that you did.
And that's a,
that's a form of prayer.
And it sounds like one
that you desperately need,
at least in principle.
No.
So
without knowing the details,
that's about the best I can do.
I think what put you over with so many
of us was the constructive message of how
to be a good man.
Well,
a good person I would say.
Do you think that's where
the media want you to go?
I don't know.
Generally not day.
I mentioned this earlier,
is that the media as it disintegrates
and it certainly is disintegrating at an
incredibly rapid rate.
Um,
everything is political there.
It's less if the philosophical and the
psychological and the theological don't
exist.
And you know,
increasingly in my interviews I've been
talking about what's been happening at
my lectures on my tour and describing
the fact that the vast majority of the
audience isn't there for
political reasons at all.
They were there because they want to
figure out how to have a responsible and
meaningful life and it's as if
that story just doesn't exist.
The the,
the framework,
which is basically a political framework
and increasingly a politically correct
framework doesn't allow
that to exist as a reality.
And that's why,
well,
I'm much more comfortable lecturing to
the crowds that have been coming to see
me then I am talking to journalists.
It's become,
I have to,
I have been limiting my,
my interactions with journalists even
though that might not be self evident yet.
I have been trying to do that,
that the demands have been increasing.
So the proportion of media invitations
that I've responding to has fallen
dramatically even though the absolute
number hasn't declined as precipitously.
And the reason for that
is that while I find the,
I find the typical
interview very stressful,
very,
very stressful.
I'm on guard.
And I would say also my attitude isn't
as good as it could be any more because
I've been,
I'm,
because I'm on guard so much,
it's easier for me to get a bit snappy
and an unpleasant and that's bad.
That's bad.
I don't want to do that.
I want to stay calm and
detached and try to,
you know,
tell the truth and be happy that I'm
there regardless of the circumstances.
Um,
the fact that the mainstream media,
let's say,
is not very receptive,
although sometimes there's exceptions,
not very receptive to the idea that I
could just be going around talking to
people who want to get their
life together is quite saddening.
And I think it's definitely a commentary
on the fundamental corruption of our
media apparatus.
I think it's better to talk on youtube,
to speak on my podcast,
to do these lectures,
and I think it's increasingly
better to do that.
The long form discussions on youtube
though with people like Joe Rogan and Dave
Rubin and,
and so forth,
that works just fine.
So the new media form is emerging and
I think it's going to be a lot more
productive.
Um,
it won't be a scripted,
it'll be much longer forum.
It will be allowed for
much more thoughtfulness.
Um,
and
I'm,
but it's okay.
It's not like the media exposure,
although it's been stressful.
It's not like I'm not grateful for it.
Even people who've put me on the spot
very badly have ended up doing me a
tremendous favor.
But the problem is,
is that because
yeah,
the problem is I'm becoming
too much on garden and I,
I've noticed,
uh,
developing sense of impatience
within me and some suspicion,
and that's not good.
I don't want to be in situations where
those are my fundamental orientations.
It's,
it's a,
it's a sign of a certain amount
of internal corruption on my part.
And,
uh,
I want to be in situations
where I'm speaking with people,
speaking honestly to people
who are honestly listening.
That would be,
that's a good situation.
So
would you agree with Cs Lewis?
That if you look for truth,
you may find comfort?
If you look for comfort,
you will find despair?
Oh yes.
That's definitely the case.
It's quite an intelligent
phrase because he says,
if you look for truth,
you may find comfort.
He didn't say you will find comfort.
Yeah.
Well,
sometimes if you look for truth,
you don't find comfort to begin with.
That's for sure.
You find a lot of trouble.
But sometimes you have to go through
a lot of trouble to get to set things
right.
If you look for comfort,
despair,
well the reason for that is that
you can't look for comfort in life.
Life isn't about comfort.
Life is a deadly game.
It's a game of life and death.
It's a game of good and evil.
It's everything's on the line.
Your sanity's on the line,
you're,
your freedom from pain is on the line.
Your freedom from despair is on the line.
Your families on the line,
there's no comfort.
Life is an adventure.
And I think the greatest adventure that
you can possibly have is one is the one
that you find if you look for the truth.
And that's a good place to stop.
That's been 90 minutes.
And uh,
I've been reasonably sharp and
with it for the full 90 minutes.
And so I think I'll bring it to a close,
just a couple of reminders for
those of you who tuned in late.
If you want to try out the
self authoring program,
I made a code August and that
an titles you did 20% off,
there's a two for one special so
you can give it to a friend as well.
If you want to try understand myself,
which is a personality test
only takes about 15 minutes.
It's quite a bit easier than
the self authoring suite.
Um,
the code for that is also August.
That also gives you 20% off.
Self authoring helps you write about
your past and present and future and you
can do a bad job and if you haven't
developed a life plan and you don't know
where you are and you don't
know where you're going,
then I would highly recommend trying the
program and you're welcome to do a bad
job at it because a bad plan is,
is a lot better than no plan at all.
And understand myself will
help you understand who you
are for better or worse.
And,
and people have responded
quite positively to it.
So I think it's worth the 15 minutes
in the nine 95 that it costs,
um,
discounted 20% now.
So I guess that's about seven 95,
something like that.
So that,
um,
the second Iceland lecturer
is going to come out soon.
I released the first Iceland lecture,
which is part of 12 rules for life.
I have a tour coming out through the
northeastern part of the United States
starting in September and then over to
the UK and northern Europe in September
and October and then Australia
and New Zealand in February.
Um,
I've really enjoyed the tour.
I think it's an amazing opportunity.
It's been extraordinarily heartwarming,
let's say,
to talk to so many people who are
trying to put their lives together.
And if enough people do that,
then they will put their lives together
and that will help put everything else
together.
And so we'll hopefully
these Q and A's are a smart,
small part that,
so thank you very much for listening in.
And I'll try to do one in September.
Um,
if I don't,
it's because I'm on the road all the time,
but I will definitely try
to do one in September.
So thank you for,
to my patrion supporters.
Um,
I mentioned to you guys that I am working
hard on the online university and have
hired three people to work
on that and that we're,
we're about a year ahead of schedule,
I would say,
where I thought I'd be,
so in three months,
we're a year ahead of
where I figured I'd be.
We'd be.
So,
um,
thanks again.
Good night.
Ciao.